tras la victoria de donald trump frente
a hillary clinton en el referéndum del
presi y la all right' extendiendo sus
tentáculos por media europa las
elecciones presidenciales de francia de
2017 fueron consideradas por muchos como
la última muralla contra el populismo y
en favor del civismo y la tolerancia
ahora cinco años después la historia en
cierto modo se repite a las puertas de
las presidenciales francesas son muchos
los candidatos y los periodistas que
mencionan la gran historia de este país
y su extenso compromiso con los derechos
humanos claro que la realidad puede ser
algo diferente y desde luego mucho pero
que mucho menos épica como dijo el
general de gaulle francia no puede ser
francia sin su grandeza cueste lo que
cueste porque si una cosa podemos tener
muy clara es que la política exterior de
francia no es precisamente un juego de
niños así que la pregunta es realmente
siempre ha sido francia ese faro de la
democracia que afirman los políticos
galos porque las acciones de este país
se ven tan diferentes fuera de francia
respecto a como ellos mismos se ven
desde dentro queridos amigos amigas este
va a ser un poco diferente a los
habituales en esta ocasión nos vamos a
centrar en poner sobre la mesa algunos
de los grandes escándalos con
repercusión internacional que ha
protagonizado el país galo esta es la
otra cara de la república francesa
atentos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
golpes de estado campañas de represión
secuestros asesinatos la política
exterior de francia no siempre se basa
en la diplomacia suave el diálogo y el
intercambio libre de opiniones a
continuación vamos a echar un vistazo a
algunos de los supuestos grandes
escándalos internacionales en los que la
república francesa ha podido estar
involucrada escándalos que han
alimentado todo tipo de sospechas
teorías de la conspiración y resquemores
algunos de ellos son rotundamente
negados por parís a pesar de lo cual
existen muchos pero que muchos motivos
para dudar otros en cambio son admitidos
con la boca pequeña pero dicho lo cual
sin más preámbulo creo que lo mejor es
que pongamos algunos de ellos sobre la
mesa y sabéis que el primero de ellos
nos lleva ni más ni menos que hasta la
mismísima latinoamérica
[Música]
la operación cóndor
durante la década de los 70 gran parte
de sudamérica estuvo bajo el control de
dictaduras que dirigieron sus países con
manos de hierro hablamos particularmente
de brasil argentina chile paraguay
bolivia y uruguay pues bien el caso es
que el día 28 de noviembre del año 1975
en la capital de chile en santiago los
gobiernos de estos países con la
excepción de brasil aunque esto no fue
un impedimento para que luego
participará activamente implementaron
oficialmente el conocido como operación
o plan condor una campaña de represión
política y terrorismo de estado para
perseguir a la oposición política
particularmente a la oposición de
izquierdas hablamos de una dura campaña
de represión en la que participaron en
un momento u otro la mayoría de los
gobiernos de sudamérica y que incluso
incluyó el asesinato de numerosos
opositores políticos el terror amigos
recorrió el conosur de arriba a abajo y
lo hizo con el firme apoyo de eeuu bajo
los gobiernos de quiera el foro jimmy
carter y ronald reagan
durante algo más de 10 años se llevaron
a cabo decenas de miles de detenciones
secuestros y extradiciones irregulares
se utilizó ampliamente la tortura y
algunas estimaciones apuntan a que
fueron más de 60.000 las víctimas
mortales que pueden atribuirse al plan
condor víctimas entre las que figuraban
guerrilleros de izquierdas pero también
disidentes políticos líderes sindicales
estudiantes intelectuales profesores
sacerdotes y campesinos
pues bien la historia nos dice que los
gobiernos sudamericanos llevaron a cabo
este plan con el apoyo fundamentalmente
de eeuu esta es la historia pero un
momento porque puede no ser toda la
historia particularmente si hablamos de
argentina y chile
y es que veréis según se ha denunciado
algunos documentos originales del
ministerio de exteriores de francia
parecen probar un acuerdo en 1959 entre
parís y buenos aires- para establecer en
la argentina una misión militar
permanente de oficiales franceses que
habían luchado en la guerra de argelia
asimismo se sospecha que el gobierno del
presidente giscard habría colaborado
activa y secretamente con la junta de
videla en argentina y el régimen de
augusto pinochet en chile de esta forma
los franceses habrían entrenado a los
servicios de inteligencia de la
dictadura argentina incluyendo formación
en técnicas de tortura y no sólo eso los
decretos de aniquilación que fueron
firmados por la presidenta isabel perón
parecen haberse inspirado en documentos
franceses anteriores
el propio reinaldo vignone nombrado
presidente de la junta militar argentina
en 1982 afirmó que el orden de batalla
del golpe de estado que llevó a los
militares argentinos al poder en 1976 se
había inspirado en la propia experiencia
francesa en argelia
como se dice en españa' blanco y en
botella luego años más tarde en el 2003
diputados del partido verde francés
solicitaron la creación de una comisión
parlamentaria para examinar el papel de
este país a la hora de apoyar
activamente a los regímenes militares de
américa del sur una comisión que no
llegó a ninguna parte porque el
responsable de dicha comisión el
diputado rolando se negó a permitir que
declararán los testigos clave
amigos el gobierno francés ha negado
activamente haber jugado ningún papel en
el plan condor sin embargo existen
muchos motivos para dudar en 2007 por
ejemplo el almirante argentino luís
maria mendia declaró ante la justicia
que la inteligencia francesa había
participado en el secuestro y el
asesinato de dos monjas francesas en el
país gaucho y este es sólo un ejemplo lo
cierto es que a pesar de las negaciones
constantes de parís los indicios parecen
acumularse sobre la mesa pero sabéis que
no hemos hecho nada más que empezar
porque si hay un territorio en el que la
diplomacia francesa es especialista y si
no es otro que áfrica atentos
[Música]
el teatro de operaciones galo
hace ya más de seis décadas más de 60
años que las colonias de francia en
áfrica comenzaron a independizarse sin
embargo bueno a pesar de ello el papel
del país galo en el continente africano
sigue siendo tan intenso que incluso
tiene su propia denominación
françafrique hablamos de un concepto que
trata de aglutinar tanto la influencia
política de francia como la influencia
que también tiene en las redes
clandestinas y repletas de corrupción y
asuntos turbios que siguen existiendo
entre la vieja metrópoli y sus antiguas
colonias o mejor dicho con las élites
con las élites que controlan sus
antiguas colonias sea como sea si hay
una cosa que siempre ha tenido clara al
gobierno de francia es su decidida
vocación por intentar mantener su
influencia internacional y seguir siendo
considerada una superpotencia mundial y
en esa estrategia amigos áfrica juega un
papel clave por eso aunque hayan pasado
60 años el peso la influencia y el poder
de francia en la región sigue siendo
simple y llanamente enorme
hablamos de un papel que durante la
grafía fue además apoyado por los
mismísimos eeuu porque pues queridos
amigos amigas durante la guerra fría
francés se convirtió en algo así como la
punta de lanza el último baluarte de
occidente para evitar que la región
cayera bajo la influencia soviética un
papel que parece tomar aún muy pero que
muy a pecho para que os hagáis una idea
francia tuvo un papel tan
intervencionista en áfrica que desde
1960 hasta mediados de los 90 liberó una
media de una intervención militar cada
año si lo habéis escuchado bien una
intervención de media por año es algo
que prácticamente deja a eeuu y al
mismísimo george walker bush como unos
auténticos principiantes en todo este
tema de las intervenciones
internacionales
[Música]
francia hecho en el continente africano
prácticamente de todo desde intervenir
para proteger a los ciudadanos franceses
y sofocar una rebelión o evitar golpes
de estado hasta propiciar los incluso no
ha dudado en eliminar a los presidentes
que suponían una amenaza para sus planes
esta es por ejemplo en la lista de
presidentes africanos en cuya
eliminación se sospecha que participó
francia
sí vale puede que la mayoría fueran
sátrapas de tomo y lomo pero con esto os
podéis hacer una idea de cómo ha jugado
francia en la región y qué queréis que
os diga tampoco es que podamos decir que
los resultados han sido particularmente
buenos si dejamos a un lado los
intereses de la propia francia claro
está así que mucho hablar de los chinas
en áfrica pero luego telita
para llevar a cabo esta estrategia no
fueron ni uno ni dos sino tres los
servicios de inteligencia franceses que
jugaron un papel muy activo en la
organización de golpes de estado y
depuración de líderes incómodos u
hostiles el servicio de documentación y
anti espionaje exterior la de gs y la de
st
[Música]
y eso eso no es todo lo cierto es que
podemos encontrar muchos ejemplos de
acciones muy pero que muy controvertidas
[Música]
por ejemplo ahí está el caso del
conocido angolagate un enorme escándalo
político relacionado con la venta y
envío secreto de armas al gobierno de
angola durante la década de los años 90
un escándalo que involucró a muchas de
las figuras más importantes de la
política francesa desde mitterrand y
jacques chirac
un caso aún mucho más oscuro es el del
asesinato en 1995 de bernardo rey un
magistrado francés destinado en yibutí
que a día de hoy todo apunta que fue
dado de baja por el propio gobierno de
yibutí y sabéis que como en ese momento
a francia le interesaba cuidar la
relación con este país africano pues
bueno todo apunta que asesoró a este
gobierno africano sobre cómo defenderse
al tiempo que también les filtró
informaciones importantes sobre las
pesquisas policiales y judiciales que
estaban en marcha
[Música]
por todo esto francia fue condenada en
2015 por el tribunal europeo de derechos
humanos y más tarde en 2020 por un
tribunal de parís por interferir en la
investigación y presionar a la defensa
de la viuda de bernat por él
ya sabéis la justicia y los derechos
humanos ante todo otro caso bien
documentado poco conocido y la prueba de
que en ocasiones las operaciones
diseñadas en despachos a miles de
kilómetros terminan muy mal es
precisamente el de ruanda me estoy
refiriendo a como francia de cierta
forma favoreció o contribuyó al gobierno
que propicia el genocidio de 1994 y es
que veréis francia apoyó activamente al
gobierno liderado por los hutus hasta el
punto que proporcionó armas y
entrenamiento militar a las milicias
hutus armas y preparación que los otros
utilizaron poco después para masacrar a
entre medio millón y un millón de
ciudadanos tutsis en apenas unos pocos
meses pero amigos áfrica no es el único
teatro de operaciones en el que francia
se ha enfrentado a fuertes polémicas un
ejemplo muy pero que muy reciente lo
tenemos en la guerra de yemen
[Música]
tanques leclerc proyectiles aviones
cazas mirage 2009 radares cobra
blindados aravis helicópteros cougar
idocin fragatas de tipo marca una
corbeta lanza misiles o cañones césar
esta es parte de la larga lista del
material militar francés usado por
arabia saudita en la guerra de yemen y
es que a pesar de las reiteradas
negativas públicas del gobierno galo
todo apunta a que en realidad francia
abrió de par en par su catálogo de armas
a los saudíes para hacer un gran negocio
con esta guerra una guerra donde la
seguridad de los civiles nunca fue una
prioridad
y no sólo eso todo apunta a que francia
también entrenó y dio apoyo logístico
arabia saudita mientras públicamente lo
negaba incluso existen informes creíbles
que apuntan a que francia llegó incluso
a desplegar fuerzas especiales en yemen
en el más absoluto secretismo 16 de
junio de 2018 fuerzas especiales
francesas sobre el terreno en yemen en
fin podríamos continuar con más y más
casos
[Música]
y es que veréis lo cierto es que aunque
los grandes medios siempre se fijen en
los escándalos y los supuestos excesos
de países como eeuu o israel en el
'viejo continente' también tenemos lo
nuestro y en el caso particular de
francia su estatus de país influyente en
el mundo es algo que se ha podido
mantener a cambio de digamos no respetar
ni promover siempre los derechos humanos
la transparencia y la justicia su
influencia y no nos engañemos también el
negocio de es importantísima industria
militar este es el precio de la grandeza
de francia pero llegados hasta aquí
turno para ti qué piensas de la política
exterior del país galo como valora su
papel en áfrica crees que la consecución
de intereses y beneficios de diferente
tipo justifican cualquier intervención
dejándonos por aquí abajo tus respuestas
y ahora es este vídeo te ha resultado
interesante no olvides darle a like y
suscribirte a visual político una vez
más muchas gracias por estar ahí un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]